but first last night Samantha B had her
first show back since she called Ivanka
Trump the c-word on full frontal that
was last week there were calls for her
to be fired she lost a couple sponsors
off her show this was how Sam open last
night's show it is a word I have used on
the show many times hoping to reclaim it
this time I used it as an insult I
crossed the line I regret it and I do
apologize for that the problem is that
many women have heard that word at the
worst moments of their lives a lot of
them don't want that word reclaimed they
want it gone and I don't blame them I
don't want to inflict more pain on them
I want this show to be challenging and I
want it to be honest but I never
intended it to hurt anyone
except Ted Cruz many men were also
offended by my use of the word I do not
care about that I hate that this
distracted from more important issues I
hate that I did something to contribute
to the nightmare of 24-hour news cycles
that were all white knuckling through I
should have known that a potty-mouthed
insult would be inherently more
interesting to them than juvenile
immigration policy I would do anything
to help those kids I hate that this
distracted from them so to them I am
also sorry and look if you are worried
about the death of civility don't sweat
it
I'm a comedian people who hone their
voices in basement bars while yelling
back at drunk hecklers are definitely
not Paragons of civility I am I'm really
sorry that I said that word but you know
what civility is just nice words
maybe we should all worry a little bit
more about the niceness of our actions
[Music]
Samantha bee is absolutely awesome
always and well obviously we talked
about this last week after it happened I
do think Samantha bee need to suffer
some kind of consequence I don't think
she really has suffered any consequence
once again I'll say again the use of
that word like what that when you say
suffer what do you mean suffer some
recon no I just think like it shouldn't
go on as normal I don't think her show
should be canceled but I think
something should have happened like I
just don't think there's any why though
why though why cuz I think you're on a
broadcast television show I don't think
it's appropriate to use that word and
there's what I said before was there's
no need to use that word it's not being
clever it's not being funny to say your
word to you though but just saying that
word is not funny that's not being
clever like I know they're trying to
make the argument oh this is comedy but
yeah but you know yeah you gonna have a
job not some part of a joke you
literally just through an insult us yeah
well you have to be so smart can really
great make these great monologues that
are so funny so clever and so biting you
just throw out that word it was
unnecessary I don't think she had to
yeah do it but it's not necessary for
you right not but it might not have been
unnecessary for her that's how you
hammer point home yeah but you're
broadcasting this to a lot of people I
just what does that accomplish by her if
she said the b-word sure okay so your
line is what so you're lying on so
you're lying on what to call somebody on
television is word specific or it's the
it's the the action of being crude to
another person I was specific no I don't
think it's the Nestle word specific I
think if she called it to be word you
would be okay um no in that same context
how she said the word no I don't think
it's necessary was trying to make a
point it's not about that is it about
the word or is it about the context what
we're okay I just think it's not clever
for her to use that you can get your
point across much better by using doing
the arguments that Samantha be all this
does it just don't think it was really
for her to throw the word you're saying
nothing no I I listen I don't think P
I'm sick of I'm tired of people having
to apologize yeah no it's true because
they are there's a mob that comes after
you and they suddenly you know what
happened with this I was all for you
know if you're a sponsor of her show you
have all the right to pull out yes 100%
you do I'm not saying that that you that
you should stick with her but when you
say something the reason people fight
for free speech is so you can say this
you do have to suffer the consequences
with it you do but where this became
something else and where I now fully
back Samantha B is when the First
Amendment
was tried to be tried to take him down
when Donald Trump said that she should
be fired right that's why that exists is
so the government can't hurt you for
saying something so as soon as the
government stepped in to hurt somebody
who's a private citizen for saying
something whether they said it on TV or
not that's what I am full on team
Samantha brown know for sure I just yeah
I just don't really get what she
accomplished by acting by adding that
word to her right for a little spiel I'm
telling ya I didn't know a whole lot
about the 1,500 kids missing until she
called Ivanka Trump to C word yeah stir
I guess Jen says it good publicity stunt
a lot of people always say that so the
policies behind this heat is behind this
the Bellas
right